my name is Richard Thaler I am a
professor of economics and behavioral
science at the Booth School of Business
at the University of Chicago
let me give you an illustration of a
nudge it's the it's funny it's one
paragraph in our book but it's by far
the most famous example from the book it
turns out some genius ooh an economist
in fact allegedly at least an economist
who works for the Amsterdam
International Airport Schiphol got the
brilliant idea to H the image of a
housefly in the urinals in the men's
bathrooms at the airport this image of a
housefly head looks extremely realistic
you can see a picture of it on our
website nudges org and it's located just
near the drain now it turns out that men
when they're taking care of their
business they're not fully attending to
the task at hand
but and I'm sure there's an evolutionary
explanation for this if you give them a
target they will aim and according to
the people who run the airport spillage
has been reduced by 80 percent
now that housefly has become my favorite
illustration of a nudge so what a nudge
a nudge is some small feature of the
environment that attract our attention
and alters our behavior
it comes down to values so when should
we nudge and when should we shove I
think it's a political judgement and
obviously in some situations we need
shoves we need laws fraud is against the
law a murder is against the law
drunk driving is against the law we
don't need just nudges on the other hand
sometimes we can combine the two so for
example in some states if you've been
convicted of DWI driving while
intoxicated after you serve your
sentence and you get your license back
you also have to equip your car with
some device that requires you to pass
some sobriety test before you turn the
car on I think that's probably a good
rule so we can push the - but but where
we're going to go on on various public
policy issues will be a political
decision where of course people will
will differ
I think the people have been the most
overconfident in our business in the
last decade have been the people that
call themselves risk managers and the
reason is they fail to learn the primary
lesson we should have learned from when
long-term capital management went
belly-up ten years ago and that is that
investments that seem uncorrelated can
be correlated simply because we're
interested in them so LTCM lost money
but when Russia defaulted on a certain
class of bonds and then they had other
investments like on the spread between
two different kinds of shares of Royal
Dutch Shell Oil Company now that seems
completely unrelated to Russian bonds
but they were related because other
hedge funds saw similar discrepancies
and they were all making similar bets so
the world is much more correlated than
we give credit to and so we see more of
what Nassim Taleb calls Black Swan
events rare events happen more often
than they should because the world is
more correlated so I think one lesson we
have to learn is that there's a lot more
risk than we're giving credit to a lot
more what economists call systemic risk
I think we also have learned the lesson
that we have to have better incentive
structures
one simple step firms can take is make
sure that people that are getting paid a
lot of money say more than a million or
two that a big chunk of that money is
deferred that's going to change the
whole ballgame because the money has to
be deferred with what they call clawback
which means they can get it back if I
lose it all so that guy who's making ten
million a year selling credit default
swaps if we're going to keep 5 million
of it in escrow for 10 years and with
the right to go back and get it if he
starts losing money then we're going to
give people the right incentives not to
take so much risk the same with the
mortgage brokers that we're selling
people mortgages they couldn't afford we
we shouldn't pay them on each mortgage
they right they should they should have
what they call skin in the game where it
they've got to reimburse us if the guy
who sold the mortgage defaults and so I
think that there are lessons that the
financial services industry can learn
and as I said they should either
aggressively take these steps on their
own or expect Congress to act
everyone's lost a lot of money in their
401k plans I've heard some people
calling them 201k plans now so it's even
more important to get people to be
saving do you saving more for retirement
behavioral economics has helped us learn
a lot about how to do that one simple
way is what's called automatic
enrollment now this is just changing
what are called the default options in a
typical 401k plan when you first become
eligible you get a big pile of forms and
you're told fill out these forms if you
want to join tell us how much you want
to save and how you want to invest the
money in under automatic enrollment you
get that same pile of forms but the top
page says if you don't fill out these
forms we're going to enroll you anyway
and we're going to enroll you at this
saving rate and in these investments if
you don't want to join then sign here
that says I don't want to join now that
increases the number of people who join
and the speed at which they join by a
huge amount there's a second component
of a good savings plan which is
something that a colleague of mine
called Shlomo Bernard see and I
developed many years ago that we call
save more tomorrow and save more
tomorrow is is a nudge to help people do
what they know they want to do which is
save more but they can't bring
themselves to save more now just like
many of us are planning to go on diets
next month or maybe in two months
certainly not tonight so here's how save
more tomorrow works a company invites
their employees to sign up for a plan
where every time they get a raise some
part of that raised goes to increasing
their country
mutant rate to the 401k plan in the
first company we convinced to adopt this
plan saving rates tripled now no one was
forced to do it right so this was a
nudge
now in 2006 Congress adopted the
following law called the Pension
Protection Act it's actually a 900-page
bill but there's two paragraphs that are
nudges and what it says is that if a
company has those two features automatic
enrollment and a primitive kind of save
more tomorrow they have to enroll people
at at least a three percent saving rate
and they have to automatically escalate
that at least 1% a year for at least
three years and if they do those two
things end they have a match so the
company contributes something to the
plan as well so they have those three
things then they get a free pass on some
compliance form that companies find very
onerous that shows that not too much of
the benefits are going to the highest
paid workers they get that free pass
because if they've adopted those things
then it's almost certainly the case that
they're in compliance now I think this
is a perfect illustration of nudging of
light-handed
regulation it's not telling companies
you must have automatic enrollment you
must have saved more tomorrow you must
have a match it's telling them if you
want to do that then here's a little
carrot you won't have to fill that form
out and I think it's a great model for
how government can use nudges in
regulation
now
there's an opportunity for new kinds of
businesses who can sell trust and it's
tricky let's take the credit card market
many credit card credit cards have been
extremely profitable to banks and
they're profitable not from the fees
they collect from the from the retailers
that use the credit cards I mean that
pays the bills but the real profits come
from the interest payments and the
charges to users that are unexpected so
I missed my payment by a day they hit me
with a $50 penalty and they increase my
interest rate by five percent now is
there a market for somebody selling a
credit card that helps people pay down
their balances and I think the question
is yes but it would have to be sold by a
bank that's really willing to invest in
being a trusted partner with its
consumers because they will make less
money on each consumer so if rather than
setting the minimum balance as the
lowest possible amount so we keep people
in debt for as long as possible we raise
the minimum payment and encourage people
to pay off their credit cards we're
going to make less money but we're going
to have customers that are more solvent
if it means here's one example very
practical example in the card
car business one thing credit card
companies often do is they'll tell you
you set you have a two thousand dollar
credit limit now you might think that
means that if I go over that the card
will be rejected no that doesn't what it
means the card companies will often as a
courtesy
honor that credit card but hit you with
a penalty and you keep swiping your card
for $3 at Starbucks for your latte and
you're getting hit with a $25 penalty
because it's over your credit limit now
it would be much more consumer friendly
for them to beep you when you swipe your
card that's a oh you're over your limit
are you sure you want to use that maybe
you'll take the cash out so a credit
card company or a bank that goes into
the business of saying we're going to be
the honest broker we're going to sell
you a mortgage that you're going to be
able to pay off we're going to help you
reduce your credit card debt we're going
to help you save for retirement we're
going to put you into mutual funds that
have low fees rather than high fees I
think there's an opportunity for such a
bank
suppose you know I'm a wine lover
suppose that's my vice that I can't walk
past a wine shop without walking in and
browsing and the next thing I know
there's some expensive bottle I'm
walking out with well I I might be
interested in a credit card that I tell
them don't honor this credit card in
wine shops or I'm not allowed to spend
more than $500 a month unwind if I go
over that stop me okay well then why
should a bank offer that credit card
right there they're making less money
unless I realize gee that's great that
they're offering me that card it's
really helping me out so when I need a
mortgage I'm going to go to them when I
need an IRA I'm going to go to them
maybe when I get older and I'm thinking
about buying an annuity I'll go to them
but it's only going to work if they
really are your trusted friend
you